you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast significance of mean cell
hemoglobin of the reticulocytes M CHR
biomarker and diagnosis of iron
deficiency anemia presented by dr. Nita
Munchie and Kristi jewel of laberd's and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by Abbott Diagnostics for more
information on our sponsor please visit
Abbott comm now let's get started I
would like to remind everyone that
today's event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
your presentation window or you can
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of your presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit
I'd now like to introduce today's
presenter dr. Anita Munchie dr. Mann she
is professor head and director of the
laboratories at Ruby Hall Hospital in
Pune India this is a group of specialty
hospitals with 750 beds she also heads
the steering committee for quality
control and is the chairperson of the
hospital infection control committee
she has also authored chapters in
pathology books and has presented papers
and posters in both national and
international conferences she's very
passionate about infection control and
hence works closely with infectious
disease clinicians for a complete
biography on dr. Munchie please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen welcome dr. Munchie you may now
begin your presentation
thank you thank you for that
introduction hello friends as she said
I'm Doc Anita maangchi from the Ruby
whole group of hospitals in Pune India
my topic today is significance of MCHR
in the diagnosis of I'm deficiency
anemia
at the outset I'd like to make my
disclosure statement which you can read
now to begin with the presentation I'd
like to just point out the learning
objective first to discuss the global
impact of iron deficiency anemia
second to describe iron metabolism
absorption regulation and storage third
review laboratory diagnosis of iron
deficiency anemia infusing new
parameters in laboratory and last I'd
like to share results of an iron
deficiency anemia study performed on the
Abbot Elana THQ analyzer in our
laboratory
now to begin with we all know thine as
an essential metal for the body it is
required for hemoglobin synthesis in be
electrified oxidation reduction reaction
and cellular proliferation body iron
metabolism is a semi closed system as
there is no definitive
excretory pathway for iron iron
deficiency anemia is the most common
anemia worldwide especially prevalent in
women and children regions where meat
intake is low food is not fortified with
iron malaria Jessen infections and
parasitic worm infestations are common
women with frequent pregnancies are
particularly susceptible in India 49
percent of the population has iron
deficiency anemia
now just to give you an overview of the
bill bill anemia prevalence about 1.5 to
1.7 billion people are affected
worldwide which accounts for twenty four
point eight percent of the world's
population prevalence of anemia is
highest in South Asia and Central and
West Africa while the causes of anemia
are variable it is estimated that half
of the cases are due to iron deficiency
now the table on the Left tells us about
the age-wise distribution of anemia
globally and as you can see preschool
aged children
account for the highest number that is
forty seven point four percent which is
equivalent to three to ninety three
million of the population affected the
second largest group is pregnant women
which account for 41 point eight percent
of the population accounting for iron
deficiency anemia and then of course we
have the non pregnant women so as I said
earlier the women and children account
for a huge proportion of on deficiency
anemia even globally
this is just to give you a map and a
visual impression of global estimate of
the prevalence of anaemia this light
tells us in infants aged six to fifty
nine months of course this data is of
2011 must have changed over the years
but this is the data that I have then
this is a slide to tell us anemia and
women of reproductive age group that is
15 to 49 years and again we can see a
huge prevalence over Africa India and
the Southeast Asian region now what are
the types of anemia just to tell you
briefly anemia is divided into the
following categories
I'm deficiency anemia anemia of chronic
diseases
Wickenden deficiency anemia
aplastic anemia and hemolytic anemia and
sickle-cell anemia which falls into the
provision of hemoglobin octopus
now patients at high risk of anemia
we've already discussed is women infants
children
[Music]
patience surgical patient chronic kidney
disease patient congestive heart failure
patient and of course chronic picture
cancer patients so cancer patients heart
disease kidney disease all fall into the
category and critically ill patients
fall into the category of chronic
diseases and they account majority of
the times for anemia of chronic disease
not just to tell you about the WH o
guidelines
Selenia because that is taken as the
core board or the baseline to diagnose
any anaemia in children six to 59 months
of age any hemoglobin 11 grams or higher
is non anaemia miles between ten to ten
point nine grams per DL moderate anaemia
is seven to nine point nine grams the BL
and severe anemia is less than seven
times the DL for children for five to
eleven years of age anything over eleven
point five grams the deal is not anemia
eleven to eleven point four so this is a
very narrow band of my Linea eight to
ten point nine is moderate and less than
eight is severe anemia and children so
as you can see children are broken up
into three categories one is 12 to 14
years of age one is five to eleven years
and then six to fifty nine months so for
twelve to fourteen years of age
anything over twelve grams is not anemia
11 - eleven point nine grams is mild
eight to ten point nine is moderate and
lower than eight grams so that is
similar to the age group of five to
eleven years
non-pregnant women twelve grams or
higher is non anaemia now your I'd like
to just point out that this is WH your
guidelines which is globally prevalent
and taken as a guideline for the global
scenario however in India and some of
the asia-pacific regions each region
needs to establish what is their mom for
calling pregnant and non-pregnant women
anemic anon anyway so as for the global
guidelines it AV 12 grams and pregnant
women 11 grams the DL or higher is non
Alenia ten to ten point nine is mild
anaemia and seven to nine point nine
grams the DP grandpa DL is moderate
anaemia however lower than seven grams
per DL in pregnant women
and less than 8 grams per deal in non
pregnant women is considered as anemia
after the WTO guidelines for the ferment
the raw guidelines are a little
different more than 13 grams per DL is
non anaemia 11 to 12 point 9 grams per
DL is mild eight to ten point nine is
moderate and less than eight grams per
DL is considered as severe anemia so we
do have a benchmarking which we can
follow and then it is up to each lab to
establish their own guideline
now coming to iron metabolism
the iron absorption
the site of absorption is usually the
duodenum or upper jejunum which is known
to everybody there are two distinct
pathways to iron absorption one for
uptake of heme iron and one for feather
sign most of the dietary iron is non
heme form which is less than 5%
bioavailable less than 10% of dietary
iron is he in form and this accounts for
more than 25% of bioavailability
now just a few
that we need to know when we talk about
iron absorption transparent sedative and
hemosiderin what is transparent it's the
plasma iron transporter protein which
carries less than 1% of total body I
ferritin is the intracellular storage of
iron and hemosiderin is the long-term
iron storage pool which is available and
seen in the bone marrow in liver and
spleen and wherever we have iron storage
now just a quick word on foods with good
source of time this is very important
for people to know because a lot of
patients do ask when we face them with
iron deficiency anemia they do ask us
what are the rich iron rich foods so
this is just a brief to show you what
are the different categories of iron
rich foods and there are basically three
group group 1 group 2 and group 3 group
1 is basically for non vegetarians which
is meats seafood and poultry group 2 is
for the veggies and the vegan which
accounts for vegetables being fruits in
that and Group three is breads and
cereals grains so this is basically a
cause this can be seen anywhere on the
net but this is just to give you a brief
on foods rich in iron now when we talk
about foods rich in iron one important
factor to remember is we should know
factors that influence iron absorption
and here I would like to state that we
have to look at inhibitors competitors
and facilitators of iron absorption
because they do influence ion absorption
and contribute towards iron deficiency
anemia
now the inhibitors are phytates tannins
which we commonly find in tea and coffee
soil clay laundry starch an overload
itself is an inhibitor which is
naturally provided in our bodies and
antacid so these are inhibitors of iron
absorption then we have competitors
where there is competition to iron
absorption and these are metals such as
lead cobalt strontium manganese and zinc
and of course we have facilitators of
iron absorption which helps in iron
absorption so if coal bit that is
vitamin C citrate minor acid to help in
absorption and and efficiency itself
acts as a facilitator suggest as I know
alowed is an inhibitor i'm deficiency is
a facilitator for iron absorption
now let me show you graphical
presentation of iron absorption now as
you can see in this diagram the what
we've shown what I'm showing is the
duodenal epithelial cell with Balai now
food iron is broken up into two parts
one is heme iron and one is the non heme
iron the heme iron is absorbed through
the epithelial cell with a gene
transporter and then further broken up
and either absorbed as mucosal keratin
or through ferroportin transported and
converted from ferrous to ferric and
stored in iron storage areas such as
blood plasma transferrin and also in the
liver and marrow the non heme iron is
either a ferric form and it's
reconverted to ferrous at the epithelial
surface and excreted however a part of
it may be taken in through the
epithelial surface with DMT one and
absorbed and taken in again into mucosal
ceratin and also to ferroportin which
then absorb the iron converts the
ferrous to ferric and helps to store it
in storage areas a part of this Nikko's
algorithm is locked by the shedding
epithelial cells and this is basically
summing up the entire process of
absorption storage and excretion of iron
in the body now let us have a word on
the key regulators of iron metabolism
hepcidin has now become a prominent
regulator of iron metabolism and we do
have analyzers which now monitor
hepcidin the main role is to innovate
and fluxes into the plasma
Pepsodent binds to the ionic sport of
the reportin which you saw in the
earlier diagram causing it's endocytosis
and lysis of the degradation which
results in cessation of cellular ionic
sport when iron is deficient hepatocytes
produce less hepcidin allowing more iron
to enter plasma when iron is abundant on
the other hand hepcidin production
increases the missing further iron
absorption and release from stores so
that hepcidin plays an important role in
regulation of iron metabolism now
looking at this diagram again here we
talked about I'm cycle and storage
daily absorption of iron is about one
milligram from the duodenum which is
then transported by transferrin in the
plasma and either taken to liver and
other parenchymal cells and tissues
especially muscle my little bit which is
then excreted in urine pieces by a male
hair and skin
the daily loss is about one milligram
we also have storage forms of character
and hemosiderin in macrophages also from
transferrin the iron is then transported
to the bone marrow into the normal class
and this normal blasts help in
erythropoiesis and are incorporated into
the circulating hemoglobin in the
erythrocyte from there
also it is taken by the macrophages
now a part of this circulating
hemoglobin iron is lost during the
menstrual period and in any form of
hemorrhage when we have loss of blood
now this slide basically somehow I'm
transport and storage affine and about 1
milligrams is what is required to form
absorption to storage and the loss is
almost balanced to this effect and it is
only when we talk about imbalance in any
of this part of the cycle where we will
end up with I am deficiency anemia not
talking about pathophysiology there are
three stages
insufficient iron supply for hemoglobin
synthesis obviously I'm mobilised from
the stores
and of course the third-stage restos
become inadequate and anaemia barrier
now what are the stages of iron
deficiency there are three stages stage
one we have the Peter dime-store
this stages is a lactic we would not
really see this the ferritin is low and
the bone marrow stores of iron are
actions or low however in this stage one
rarely does bone marrow
you know ferritin may be done if a lab
or a pathologist or a clinician is smart
enough to pick up low indices in a CBC
report h2 is latent and efficiency where
you have low transferrin saturation low
serum iron reseeding haptoglobin and
normal hemoglobin
this stage also is latent and me or may
not be picked up because the hemoglobin
is still normally it is only the indices
which are low and stage 3 is iron
deficiency and Nina there's low
hemoglobin and low he back crypt with
look indices on iron deficiency anemia
report on a hemoglobin immigrant report
compares the clinician to work up the
patient further to prove that the
patient has got iron deficiency and we
would further test the patient for
ferritin and other parameters now we
will be talk about laboratory diagnosis
the commonest test asked for is a
complete blood count or a CBC as we call
it when we see a low hemoglobin low
hematocrit low RBC count low MCV low and
CH and low and CSC with a high RDW we
all know and laboratory people as well
as clinicians know that this points
towards fine deficiency anemia
then we look at a peripheral blood smear
and it shows hyper chromia with micro
psychosis and I saw a kilo psychosis
pencil says maybe target cells and we
confirm a diagnosis of I'm station C
anemia now this is just to show you a
peripheral blood film what it looks like
but that smear shows us hypochromic with
an ISO psychosis pencil-shaped cells and
the right slide shows a lot of white
hello psychosis elect side and this is a
classic picture of iron deficiency
anemia now once iron deficiency anemia
suspected of biochemical markers are
usually asked for by the clinician to
confirm a diagnosis of iron deficiency
and what are they
Sedo mine cibc ferritin soluble
transferrin receptor pre erythrocyte
protoporphyrin inhibited and we get a
low seer mine
elusive transferrin saturation but high
tea IBC
a low serum ferritin grease Saluda
transferrin receptor increased free
electrified protoporphyrin and low serum
Pepsodent levels now let me point out at
this page back the last three parameters
and share Li them as routine by any lab
only a very very specialized lab we do
these parameters a normal or routine or
even a high value lab maybe only serum
int IDC and sedatives so there is a
limitation on diagnosis of iron
deficiency anemia or it's confirmation
by by McBride chemical markers then we
look at the bone marrow examination
editor process is usually micro normal
blastic because the iron stores of iron
already utilized there is absence of
stainable iron and the bone marrow on
pearls fashion being stained on the left
is the control slide on Prussian blue
which shows a good iron storage and on
the right is iron deficiency they cannot
see any iron stores
thus let's look at the new parameters
now we must understand that today we
have a lot of new automated analyzers
and the providers with tests that are
independent of infection and
inflammation we all know that ferritin
and iron are acute phase reactants and
are easily affected by infection and
inflammation and hence companies and
manufacturers have come out with new
parameters which are not influenced by
infection and information and they are
zinc coated for Fyren soluble
transferrin receptor particular site
hemoglobin content also known as event h
ii by sis NEX
right hemoglobin contains known as EHRs
by Siemens Adria and means cell
hemoglobin of the reticular sites that
is MCHR by Abbott so these are some of
the new parameters available to us on
the new automated analyzer in a hill
ecology lab
now one approach would be to identify
newly formed and efficient cells when
they are released from the bone marrow
as ridiculous I now these ridiculous
heights a new newly formed independent
RBC and they would be a very good
parameter to analyze because they would
be rich an uncontained flow Saito metric
analysis of particular types allows
determination of the mean cell
hemoglobin of the particular site that
is MCHR some analyzer may also provide
percent hypochromic RBC's example
percent HP or by Abbott but this is
available only as a research use
parameter and cannot be used for giving
patient results commercially in
commercial labs
the percentage do measure is regarded as
a time averaged marker of unrestricted
Eric through poison
now the lifespan is 120 days for an a
red cell and that is why it is taken as
a measure for iron restricting
electrophoresis between 20 to 120 days
but the MCHR is a measure and a real
time parameter which allows us to
measure the hemoglobin content in the
reticular side for up to 48 hours
now coming a little more into MCHR what
is MCHR as i said earlier it is a mean
cell hemoglobin of the particular site
it is determined the cellular level
early detection of iron deficiency also
useful for diagnosis of functional iron
deficiency and for monitoring with
consciousness to iron therapy and any
proposals stimulating agent and this is
very important so in addition to early
detection of iron deficiency we can
monitor patient on I'm therapy with this
it monitors a few changes in hemoglobin
incorporation into the era thrown at the
site the more sensitive than indirect
chemical method and compared with erekle
site the shorter lifespan of
reticulocytes
makes this parameter a better biomarker
to reflect i'm state i'm status in the
short-term
therefore MCHR represents an attractive
alternative for the diagnosis of iron
deficiency especially in countries with
high prevalence like in India where I
come from it has more stable it's a very
stable assay rather so even if the
rheticus site volume changes due to a
delay in sample processing the MCHR
content does not change because as I
said earlier it is stable for almost 48
hours now I would like to run you
through a B that we did at our Hospital
in our laboratory
and it was basically for our confidence
to establish the efficacy and efficiency
and importance of MCHR so what we did is
we took a sample size of 50 control
group and 50 patients with on deficiency
anemia it's 50 and 51 now the control
group was basically patients who visited
our health check-up department were
normal healthy adult when men had a
hemoglobin of more than 13 leginfo DL
and females had immigrant of more than
12 milli density s the MCV was normal
and CH was normal and MCHC was normal in
the iron deficiency anemia group where
we had 51 patients the hemoglobin for
men was less than 13 and for females
with less than 12 the MCV was less than
80 temple eaters MCH was less than 27
micrograms and MCHC was less than 33
grams per TF so it fulfills the criteria
of iron deficiency anemia and the
biochemical parameters confirmed and
efficiency with an iron less than a
serum iron less than 50 microgram per DL
a TI BC more than for 25 micrograms the
DL and in serum ferritin worth less than
10 nanograms per ml that's showing us
that these were confirmed iron
deficiency and population then we looked
at the NC a child in both the population
about the groups that is the control
group and the ID a group as you can see
the control group at mean MCHR of 31.5
one microgram with the range of 28 to 36
points or and a median of 31.4 Piko
grams that is the ID a group at a mean
and chr of 23 points for one micrograms
a range of fourteen point seven to
twenty seven point five with the median
of twenty-three point one five
micrograms which clearly shows us that
the MCHR is a very good parameter to
measure and deficiency anemia that
friends I would like to highlight this
with a screen shot of the same one of
the patients that we had considered and
included in this study where a CDC where
the hemoglobin was eight point one two
grams per DL the MCD were sixteen point
five MCH 18 and CH three twenty nine
point seven and the MCHR was nineteen
point one my co tram the chemistry
showed iron of serum iron of 11 t IBC
4:30 and 13 of seven point six it is
important that MCH are interpreted in
conjunction with other laboratory
results now for us it was very important
to establish and gain confidence that
MCH are really is a two parameter and
Bachus Phi it was very important for us
to measure the care by chemistry
parameters fibers in ASCII so that we
could establish and confirm a diagnosis
of iron deficiency and then look at the
MCH are to gain and to get our own
confidence in the laboratory then we
looked at the economic value and
obviously the battery cost can be
containment is always an important
consideration worldwide no matter which
part of the world you are in and more so
in countries with resource restriction
sentence EHR can be done on the same
sample used for CDC it is a huge value
addition and represents a cost sensitive
screening test for iron deficiency
anemia reference ranges for hemoglobin
content of reticulocyte is dependent
on the technology MCHR reference range
is different from both let AG as well as
CHR and each parameter will have to have
a lot of studies to establish what is
the reference range now we did only a
population study of 50 samples and 50
control group but we are now going to
extend it to a much larger population so
that we know and establish our own
reference range for MCHR and it would be
my advice to all my fellow colleagues
that if you have the option of rated G
or CHR or you CH are you should
establish your own reference ranges but
believe me friends this is a huge value
addition to us and to clinicians and
more so to patients because in a simple
CDC sample we are able to confidently
tell our clinicians that this patient
does fall into the category of iron
deficiency anemia without subjecting the
patient to an extra draw for biochemical
parameters so the fat is reduced the
patient's draw is reduced and the
patient can immediately be started on
treatment of the clinician the TAT for
heme of Hema gram the complete blood
count is much lower than biochemical
parameters and the patient can
confidently be spotted on treatment and
the patient can be followed up as I told
you earlier with an MCH are to establish
whether the patient is improving on the
iron therapy thank you my dear friends
and now I'm open to questions so please
feel free to ask any questions that you
would like to thank you
Thank You dr. monkey for your
informative presentations we will now
start the live Q&A portion of our
webinar if you have a question you would
like to ask please do so nails just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we
will answer as many of your questions
we have taped for okay let's get started
dr. mancine with some great questions
coming in let's start with this one how
did I actually how does how does your
laboratory educate physicians on the
availability of MCHR and the clinical
interpretation of the assay
thank you hmm that's a good question to
start off because that's always a
challenge for the laboratories what we
do is we usually invite up clinicians at
least once a year if not more often to
the lab to educate them on all the new
parameters and new equipment that we
have in the laboratory and then we tell
them about the new parameters we've
started like we did with the MCHR so we
do that plus we always I send out mails
and whatsapp messages nowadays with
social media so that they are constantly
reminded of the new parameters that you
started in the laboratory and we have a
very good interaction with our
clinicians throughout the hospital we
are huge huge Hospital but despite that
and despite having a lot of clinicians
me and my colleagues we try to maintain
a very good network with the clinicians
and I think that has helped us a lot
thank you dr. Munchie now our next
question how do you convince clinicians
to use a cellular marker over
traditional chemistry markers that are
well-known for I da well that's another
good question
thank you see it is very important when
clinicians look at patients they're
looking at cost containment and that to
parameters that are very concerned about
and by providing information from a
simple or a single CBC you report if we
can give them more information like I
mentioned in one of my slides that this
is a huge value addition it not only
reduces draws for the patient it also
reduces the turnaround time that because
then the laboratory would be able to
give information from the CDC where the
run time is much shorter then wait for
the biochemical parameters which take
longer to turn out so overall it's a
benefit to the patient and patient care
from a clinicians point of view
I think that document sighs are you
happy yes
does thank you how does MCH are compared
to the other methodology to measure
reticulocyte hemoglobin available on the
market thank you very very important
question today we have a I think there
are three prior three equipments in the
market and which gives the Miller
parameters we have one from Siemens
which gives us what is known as CHR then
we have two smacks which gives the red
itchy or reticulated hemoglobin and the
a linetti from abbott which gives MCHR
now basic principle of testing remains
the same because they all use RNA based
dyes and the flow cytometry method
however I think what is important is in
there when you look at the normal range
in the different methodologies it is
important to know that the there is an
overlap I mean I am referring to one of
the articles which came out in the blood
in 2016 by the American Society of
ontology which was performed on the X
and analyzers of this next usefulness of
rheticus reticulocyte hemoglobin
equivalent for diagnosis of iron
deficiency anemia there is an overlap in
the reference ranges of normal and iron
deficiency anemia the range was twenty
five point nine to thirty eight with an
average of 34 there is idea was fifteen
point one to thirty five point six so
there is an overlap in the reference
ranges whereas if you look at the ulema
t HQ the bias in the ranges is
eliminated and there is no overlap in
the reference ranges between the normal
population and the iron deficiency
anemia in the females had also published
the article in one of the turkish
journals of him tal G so I think the
references are available in the you know
indexed libraries and in libraries to
refer to but what
see is that we should have a clear cut
difference in the reference ranges
between a normal population and iron
deficiency anemia because if there is an
overlap it gets very confusing not only
for the clinicians but even for the
laboratory personnel so that's where I
find the difference and I find the
allottee sector as far as the picking up
of mine deficiency anemia from tha CHR
is concerned from a CDC report very good
thank you could you clarify what the
normal range for M th RS by normal range
or yes in a normal healthy population
the reference range which has been
calculated from various studies is
twenty five point three to thirty five
point five with a mean of about thirty
point thirty four I would say about 30
or 31 would be the mean and the range
would be twenty five point three to
thirty five point five but again here I
would like to specify that these are
studies conducted by different regions
of the world and I would still feel that
every laboratory using the parameter
should do a good study to establish
normal reference ranges for their own
laboratory because that is what
ultimately comes like in India we cannot
use a reference range which has been
established in the u.s. in the West or
in Australia and East so we should have
our own reference ranges and even within
yeah I would say that each laboratory
should have their own reference range
thank you dr. Munchie can we get low
MCHR with normal CBC indices and can it
pick up impending iron deficiency anemia
not yet observed as I would say you know
we haven't seen it yet
normal CDC indices and allo mph are we
would need more studies I guess to know
whether we would be finding a lo MCHR
with normal indices we haven't seen it
but then again like I said we need a
much much bigger study to be able to
pick it up and I'm looking forward to
doing such a study and hopefully if we
have enough data we would be happy to
publish it and I'm sure then we can
share it with you and you can share it
with your viewers thank you
thank you how much
let's see and let me rephrase this here
[Music]
with this question is there any
additional reagent for the MCM chr test
yes the special reagent there is a
ridiculous ITRI agent which comes
separately to any analyzer which
predicts anything to do with ratings
whether it is percentage rate eggs or
reticulated platelets or IRF or
ridiculous mo globin would need the
reticle site reagent which will help
picking up all the ridiculous ID
associated parameters
Thank You Alton let's go with this
question how much does the cost of CBC
increase when we include this additional
parameter is it lower than the cost of
chemical analysis very good question
again in resource crunch country's very
very important the cost of CBC would be
increased because of the additional
ridiculous i-tree agent that has to be
incorporated by the laboratory but still
less than the biochemical parameters
that would be added because the cost of
the chemistry's would be zero mind dibc
ferritin so if you put that and along
with the special biochemistry parameters
which any lab would test definitely it
would be cheaper to do it on a CBC with
a retic mode because the cost wouldn't
go up so much and ultimately it's not
only important for diagnosis but it is
also important to monitor therapy of the
patient and therefore it would be
important to do it by a CBC so you're
not only giving a quick turnaround time
lesser drawers lesser cost to the
patient and monitoring therapy after
institution of therapy for the patient
so I think overall yes even if you
increase the cost of CBC it would still
suffice to be less than what would cost
by adding biochemistry tests thank you
dr. Bunji are there any large Indian
population studies available for MCHR
not yet I mean I've done a literature
search and I have not seen any huge
population studies available in the
Indian population yet but again like I
said looking forward to doing it and
hopefully if we are able to do it we may
be one of the first to do such
population study unless somebody else is
already doing it and is going to publish
it soon we'll have to wait and watch for
the next few years because you see these
are very new parameters in the market
not many people are exposed to these new
parameters
so once the laboratories get used to
working on these parameters and the
confidence is built up I think then the
laboratories will be picking up these
parameters to do population studies and
we will be seeing some you know data
coming out into the market so we'll have
to wait and watch good being positive we
should be seeing some soon thank you
excellent thank you now dr. Mann she is
there a difference between MGH our
values
age-wise in a comparison between a child
and an adult
you know again that needs to be
established like I said we don't have
enough studies and so far like we in our
lab studied only on the adult population
so likewise once our confidence is there
now now like we are sure about doing it
in the adult population I think we have
to extend our studies across not only
different ages the different population
groups to come out with specific facts
so as of now not yet established thank
you thank you and we have so many great
questions coming in I want to remind our
audience that those questions we are not
able to answer to today and those
questions that come in during the on
demand period they will be answered via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration ok let's
continue in our live Q&A here of dr.
Munchie have you seen any correlation
between red H E and M CHR
well I haven't studied both the
instrument together but a very good
question because we've just got the
other instrument and maybe we in our
laboratory are fortunate that we have
both the options of MCHR and rata G and
maybe in future we may have a
comparative study to compare the two so
far we've only studied it studied the
MCHR parameter but yeah very good
question that we should have a
correlation established in our
laboratory between Rhetta G and M CHR
and maybe I can share it with you later
on in a year or two to let you know how
it could build the journal studies that
we have like I mentioned earlier the
American Society of histology study
where a red itchy population and mean of
the Reta cheese for normal and
iron-deficiency showed an overlap of the
ranges whereas we had a distinct
difference in the ranges on MCHR so that
we have published data already which
people can refer to but yes maybe some
lab like us can do a comparative study
and then come out with more specific
answers to this question very good
question
thank you
dr. manchak can we reflect MCHR to low
hemoglobin in an instrument
sorry can you reflect the same teacher
to low hemoglobin in the instrument yes
is that the question oh yes yes
sometimes we can that's yes we can and
that's one of the positives
are there controls available for the
parameter like what is your CV and
reproducibility
yes the controls are available and from
Abbott I don't think there are
guidelines CV we don't have the CV or
reproducibility yet but I know the
controls are available and I think again
the labs will have to establish their
own CV for the controls once they have I
don't remember my CV offhand but I can't
tell you maybe later on I can message
you and you can share it with the person
who's asking the question thank you
very good thank you now dr. mushy what
are the causes of false negative
positive MCHR in your experience so far
hahaha the question very good questions
coming through amis a [ __ ] the studies
done so far that we've done like in a
laboratory that I have seen so far no
false negative of false positives
observed but a bigger study probably
will highlight it to get any false
negatives or false positives which also
includes interference with the
hemoglobinopathies supposing the ever
hemoglobin apathy and we have a lot of
NRB steal we will have to establish and
see whether there is an interference of
the MCHR for such patient so false
negatives and false positives will be
thrown up when we see such patients and
we will be establishing that over over
due course of time
thank you now dr. Munchie as we were
speaking about controls just a moment
ago how many levels of controls are
available
there are three levels of controls
available for this life for any other
hematology parameter thanking you now
are there any changes observed in
newborn and infant values
I think this is the same as what we you
know went over a little earlier that
studies have been established in adult
population we don't have data on newborn
or infant values but if we want to win
the confidence of pediatricians you know
it is very important especially I
appreciate the question because in the
pediatric population on your natal
population it is difficult to get blood
drawn so if we can cut down draws for
the child it will be very important for
pediatricians and neonatologist too and
we would be of great help to them if we
can establish MCH our values in a
neonatal or a pediatric population so I
think we will have to extend the study
and divide the population into neonates
and even in the pediatric population
will have to probably divide it into two
categories between five and 14 so that
we can help them with normal ranges of
reference ranges of MCH are in that
population but as of now known but very
good food for thought thank you
thank you dr. Muntean I believe we have
time for one more question would Khan
come in hemoglobinopathies or a
hemolytic anemia with raised
reticulocyte NR BC affect the values of
MCHR how will interpretation vary in
such cases for example at thalassemia
patient having iron deficiency
thank you again I think I just answered
that a couple of minutes back where we
were talking about false negatives and
false positives in MCHR where I
mentioned that hemoglobinopathies
specially thalassemia major where we may
see a lot of NRB sees may may select and
give us a correlation whether it is a
false negative or a false positive and
CHR but we need to study Palestinian
major patients who are undergoing
hemolysis and then establish the mth our
values you know today we are in an era
of a polycythemia major patients are
very well transfused and we rarely see a
patient who comes with accurate analysis
but I think it's a very important
question and if you correlate this with
the previous question on false negatives
and false positives we must run MCHR in
patients with analysis with all major or
any other acute haemolysis and then see
the correlation 4mph our value and see
whether we are getting a false negative
of false positive in such patients so we
will have to establish data on that and
then come out with more specific answers
thank you I hope that answers the
question
thank you and let's squeeze this one
question and real quick um what about
MCHR in dimorphic anemia
dimorphic anemia again I think that's a
very valuable point to validate we need
to validate all these different
population studies because in a
dimorphic anemia we are going to see a
mixed population so we may get a false
negative MCHR I have not established
this in my study and I think we will
have to look at dimorphic anemia because
if you're going to have a mix of
population we we or may not see a low
MCHR so I think this is again food for
thought and I think we should have
another webinar maybe a year down the
line there we have more specific Studies
on all the questions that have been
asked wonderful questions pediatric
population hemoglobinopathies dimorphic
anemias I think these are very important
real life situations where we will need
to do studies for establishing reference
ranges of MCHR and interestingly come
out with answers for all these specific
conditions in a year or year and a half
and discuss it again I think it's an
excellent forum for all these answers I
think I think that's all that I can say
for now thank you thank you dr. Munchie
now before we go to you have any final
comments for our audience
I can only say that this has been an
excellent audience and with their kind
of questions that we've got it's been so
interesting and given so much food for
thought that I must congratulate the
audience for coming out with such
wonderful question
so I think it has been a wonderful
interaction and I really look forward to
doing these specific studies in the
coming year with all the questions that
have been thrown to us and to me and I
hope to come out with the positive
answers at the end of the study that we
may be doing in a laboratory at the end
of the year so I must thank you for
g'nite in such an interesting webinar
and the audience for being so
interactive and so good thank you so
much it's been a wonderful interaction
and a very pleasurable meeting for me
thank you
and thank you dr. Munchie and I too
would like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their excellent
question I do want to remind our
audience that those questions we did not
have time for today and those that are
submitted during the on-demand period
will be answered via email to the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration I would once my
pardon me I would like to once again
thank dr. Munchie for her time today and
her important contribution to infection
control we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor Abba Diagnostics
for underwriting today's educational
website this webcast can be viewed on
demand and lab routes will alert you via
email when it is available for replay we
encourage you to share that with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now and we
hope to see you again soon
have a great day
thank you